I'm Mike and I created Surf's Up surf
set really started out of necessity I
couldn't get to the ocean
I really loved the way that the body
type and the fitness level that I
attained while surfing so I needed to
create a workout that can mimic that
this is your at-home surf set workout
today we are going to be doing a very
explosive workout centered around
balance serves that stuff so we've got
some medicine balls here I've brought in
some tools to make a little more
challenging okay so first exercise we're
gonna jump into here it's going a
weighted body via ok so we got our
medicine ball sit down on the ground
bring our feet forward weight behind
head
we got 20 you can go with the weight
here comfortable with all right from
here we're gonna extend up bring the
ball up a controlled point it up at the
end alright so we're gonna go 15 seconds
on that and win it no pause we're going
right into Russian twists
so keep going 15 seconds have that timer
running then from here next one's gonna
be side planks all right so best way
stay on the ground
alright start your knees bring your
right hand over walk your feet out
stabilize all right from here all we're
trying to do you can even lower down
from you a little tricep or if you want
more oblique bring that foot up and hold
obviously switch so you roll it over the
other side okay next one you have
woodchoppers okay so for choppers come
back up right here now this is Oakley so
that's we're talking about that core
rotation right so you're working on
those stabilizer muscles so as you come
down I'll whip this guy
make sure we're switching sides
all right last one my favorite it's
medicine ball slams so we're gonna bring
the ball up over our heads bring it all
the way down you can slam it
these might run away from us a little
bit so I would say try and hold onto it
Oh me up now
and if we try one slam all right didn't
go anywhere I like that little out of
authority
15 seconds on these yet for him wait to
the toes right out focus on the core
again but gonna be balancing one point
of contact on the floor word exam oh
he's got it
areas in this shop a little pause at the
top you got it give me one more nice
alright now we're coming right up
rushing twists stabilize there you go a
lot the farther you go sign aside you've
got it
definitely work in the balance nice work
all right
counting out of that we're going right
in this side plank alright so now we're
focusing on that left oblique now if you
want to make it a little bit more
difficult you can lift that foot if
you're feeling good make sure focus on
that using that core there he is
stabilize that's it let's go three two
one all right huh I'm going woodchopper
so left to right all the way up get it
up over the head that's it
one more on that side switch over that
left nice last one all right medicine
ball slams go for here we go ready
Wow so it's recap this explosive balance
for the out serve set style we started
off with the weighted bodybeast or
follow me you square those up with that
mess of all their pickling seconds back
went into the Russian twists immediately
after that 15 seconds those then we went
into the side plank 15 seconds per side
into the woodchoppers threw that ball up
and over 15 seconds from those and then
we did the medicine ball slams to finish
it all off through twice that gives you
your three minute serve set explosive
balanced workout make sure to subscribe
so you don't miss out on any other
fighting weight episodes
you